bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
un nouvel épisode du feuilleton de la
présidentielle que nous allons suivre
jusqu'à son terme tous les dimanches
dans cette émission un épisode dans
lequel nous allons nous demander si
cette campagne n'est pas en train de
rebattre tout simplement les cartes de
la vie politique française
entre les difficultés des partis
historiques et l'apparition de nouvelles
forces sur ce plateau avec nous rémi
delattre bonjour donc je vous vous êtes
député les républicains de côte d'or et
on peut le dire soutien de la première
heure de françois fillon
tout à fait jérôme name bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le responsable de la campagne
des manuels macron en côte-d'or et yves
hollinger bonjour bonjour également vous
êtes membre du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste dont philippe poutou
porte les couleurs pour cette
présidentielle
nous avions annoncé sur les réseaux
sociaux sur internet la participation de
la conseillère régionale du front
national isabelle de lyon elle n'est pas
là elle nous a annoncé par un mail que
la présidente du groupe sophie montel je
cite n'avait pas autorisé cette
participation nous le regrettons on est
bien loin de la posture et du discours
du front national qui se plaint
régulièrement de ne pas avoir accès aux
médias la réalité vous le voyez tout
autre on peut se demander d'ailleurs si
ce nouveau refus eu quelque chose à voir
avec la mauvaise passe judiciaire que
traverse le parti de marine le pen avec
la mise en examen de sa chef de cabinet
sans oublier les enquêtes en cours sur
le financement du parti avec là encore
une mise en examen c'est une question
que j'ai envie de vous poser tout de
suite les affaires on en parlera règle
de la ve vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir
on a l'impression en même temps que les
affaires il concerne le front national
pour l'instant ça ne les touche pas
électoralement en tout cas dans les
sondages de votre point de vue pourquoi
madame le pen a l'habitude des affaires
même le pen a l'habitude des affaires en
tout cas ce qui est surprenant dans ce
que vous venez de dire c'est que
aujourd'hui la conseil régional qui
devait débattre avec nous soit absente
et je crois que ça montre tout à fait
l'état d'esprit de cette formation
politique où la notion de liberté
liberté de la parole liberté
d'intervenir est bien éloigné de ce
qu'on peut imaginer en démocratie c'est
tout l'inversé de ce que nous souhaitons
avec françois fillon
jérôme m
moi je suis un petit peu surpris parce
que c'est vrai que le front national il
ya quelques semaines quelques mois par
led tolérance zéro est à la fois on
s'aperçoit que par rapport à cette
tolérance zéro ils ne l'appliquent qu
aux autres et par et pas eux mêmes pour
ce qui est de ses affaires moi je
souhaite et pour le mouvement en marche
emmanuel macron nous ce qu'on souhaite
c'est qu'on puisse présenter notre
projet le projet qui a été construit par
les plus de 200 mille citoyens en marche
aujourd'hui comprend qu'on a travaillé
depuis neuf mois avec un diagnostic
auprès des français on a rencontré plus
de cent mille français on a travaillé
avec eux on a présenté le diagnostic à
l'automne et on va y venir
effectivement nous ce qu'on souhaiterait
c'est que ce temps démocratique ne soit
pas volée aux français et que les
affaires depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant nous empêche de débattre sur
le fond et c'est ce que nous souhaitons
c'est en marche avec emmanuel macron
s'est proposé un projet pour la france
et pour les français
niveau là j'ai dit est ce que c'est
parce que au front national il ya une
peur d'avoir à affronter cette situation
r tout état de cause ce n'est pas
étonnant comme attitude puisque même la
candidate
s'abritant derrière l'immunité
parlementaire qui est destiné en
principe à préserver la liberté de
parole pas se couvrir par rapport à des
affaires douteuses refusent de se rendre
aux convocations judiciaires
c'est une politique qui consiste à nier
ses propres responsabilités ses propres
cadavres dans les placards
tout en prétendant que tous les autres
c'est un immense complot on voit ça
ailleurs avec monsieur donald trump par
exemple alors l'autre évènement de cette
semaine c'est bien sûr l'accord
intervenu entre françois bayrou et
emmanuel macron
jérôme name c'est à voir françois bayrou
avec vous c'est une façon de l'empêcher
de vous piquer des voix au premier tour
où c'est plus largement l'idée d'un
centre qui se met en place par rapport à
d'autres grands anciens on pense à
mendès-france à de l'or à des gens qui
ont qui ont rêvé ça a d'abord la
nouvelle de cette semaine que françois
bayrou nous rejoignent c'est d'abord une
très bonne nouvelle pour nous c'est
c'est la preuve de notre mouvement de
rassemblement qu'il avait mais le
mouvement dans marché est un mouvement
bienveillant nous tendons la main à
chacun et à chacune
parce que ce que nous souhaitons c'est
rassembler tous les français sur un
projet progressiste
un projet qui redonne confiance à la
france et nous ne sommes pas danser dans
ces petites histoires et c'est une bonne
nouvelle c'est une bonne nouvelle aussi
il ya un autre françois c'est françois
de rugy qui nous a rejoint aussi cette
semaine le même jour d'ailleurs et est
donc effectivement ce rassemblement de
tous les français qu'on préconise depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
eh bien c'est ce qui est aussi en train
de se mettre en place au niveau des élus
des gens qui ont pu avoir des
responsabilités politiques dans les
années qui viennent de passer et ce
rassemblement effectivement si nous
achèverons françois bayrou du monde
agricole des catholiques
or françois bayrou c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours mis la morale publique en
premier plan qui est qui et qui a
toujours souhaité que cette morale voilà
s'instaure en politique et c'est quelque
chose auquel le mouvement en marche est
très attaché nous avons une exigence de
probité sur nos candidatures aux
législatives
il n'y aura pas de personnes qui ont eu
un casier judiciaire je trouve qu'on
joue cool parce qu'on essaie de
connaissions parole à tout le monde
rémi delattre il paraît que dans le qg
de françois fillon les gens de tirer un
peu la tête en sachant que françois
bayrou avait décidé de rejoindre madame
macro vrai que c'est assez amusant quand
même puisque françois bayrou il dit ni
droite ni gauche emmanuel macron eddy et
droite et gauche ni et je crois que
c'est vraiment nier effectivement ce
qu'attendent les français des français
ils veulent aujourd'hui un projet qui
soit claire un projet qui soit défini
et j'ai envie de vous dire c'est tout
l'un vers ce que vous proposez on voit
aujourd'hui toutes les a présentés là où
je rame effluents ses contradictions qui
entoure
emmanuel macron et j'ajoute que quand il
dit je revendique l'immaturité et
l'inexpérience c'est justement ce que
les gens ne veulent plus aujourd'hui les
gens ils veulent au contraire des gens
qui soient forts d'un projet qui soit
déterminé qu'ils aient une expérience
alors certes monsieur macro il
al'expérience faut quand même pas
oublier que c'est un homme de gauche
qu'on le veuille ou non il a écrit le
programme de françois hollande il ya
maintenant cinq ans l'accusé ministre de
monsieur hollande est aujourd'hui le
convoi france il est enlisé et il faut
se poser la question comment est-ce
qu'on va le sortir et françois fillon
propose un vrai programme pour sortir la
france est sur le point de départ de
notre émission on disait est ce que les
cartes sont pas en être battu dans la
vie politique vous avez dit les français
ils ont plus envie ils ont envie de
quelque chose de clair mais ce que les
français ils ont envie des partis
politiques anciens historique où est ce
que justement cette offre parce qu'on
voit bien que dans les sondages en tout
cas il ya une part de l'électorat qui
est intéressé alors volatiles connaître
mais intéressé y'a pas grand chose de
nouveau entre 2017 et 2012
monsieur bayrou il avait déjà été du
côté de la gauche il a soutenu françois
hollande il a fait il est en france le
groupe et il avait à une époque trahi
déjà son camp en 2007 lorsqu'il avait
été faire ses offres à madame royal
s'est ou non je mentionnerai girl and i
see il a jamais eu connaissance il n'a
jamais eu cette constance qui aurait pu
construire effectivement un centre comme
la veille rêver giscard d'estaing deux
français sur trois mais la france
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'elle est
entre c'est un centre droit c'était un
centre droit mais deux français sur
trois ça voulait dire qu on élargissait
effectivement on faisait bouger les
lignes
s'il ya des lignes qui peuvent bouger
c'est vrai et nous avons à droite chez
françois fillon des personnes qui sont
engagées nouvellement à droite tout
simplement parce qu'elles veulent rompre
avec cette politique
avant ils volent un gène une réponse de
gm sur les centres vous êtes le
le vol retour du centre de valéry
giscard d'estaing non nous ne nous
sommes pas un mouvement qui se
revendique au centre nous sommes un
mouvement qui souhaite rassembler tous
les français
les français qui viennent de gauche de
droite du centre aujourd'hui avec
françois bayrou
nous souhaitons rendre un rassembler
tous les progressistes de ce pays il ya
chez nous des gens qui viennent des
républicains il ya des chez nous des
gens qui viennent du modem qui sont des
gens aussi qui est parfois s'abstenait
qui ne croyais plus en la politique
de nombreux citoyens qui s'engagent tous
les jours dans des associations dans les
mouvements des bénévoles
c'est ça notre expérience c'est à dire
que cette expérience de citoyens nous la
mettons à la disposition de notre
mouvement et nous souhaitons aujourd'hui
nous investir en politique pour pour
faire profiter notre pays de 2,7 de
cette expérience
et pour terminer sur l'échelle
évidemment nous nous souhaitons
rassembler tous les progressistes y
compris de gauche et d'autres vont venir
nous rejoindre et demain des
républicains et de gauche bien sûr on va
y revenir
il voyage et vous attendez patiemment
quand vous voilà je voulais que cet
échange se fasse pour que vous puissiez
me il ya effectivement une désaffection
profonde des normes de citoyennes et
citoyens par rapport à la vie politique
telle qu'elle est structuré depuis
longtemps et de ce point de vue là je
suis désolé mais ce sont des supers où
monsieur fillon ou quelle autre c'est le
retour j'allais dire des mêmes pour
faire les mêmes et dans ce cas là nous
n'avons rien à attendre
moi ce qui me frappe c'est que l'on nous
propose en fait d'un côté une nouvelle
formation en marche et c'est qu'ils
visent à faire en plus dur le programme
de droite qui a été celui de monsieur
hollande parce qu'il faut appeler un
chat un chat
il ya longtemps que parti socialiste
fait un programme qui est celui que
réclame le medef qui est monsieur macron
à appliquer pendant des années et il
n'est pas du tout le bois le monde
quitte de cette participation
alors ça c'est le premier élément parce
que je vois c'est que la protestation
citoyenne
elle se traduira pas ou en tout cas pas
par des formations électorale
attrape-tout elle se traduit par
d'autres choses dévouement fort
intéressants comme celui qu'on a connu
au printemps et qui a accès prolongation
actuellement qu'on appelle une nuit
debout mais qui pour l'instant n'a pas
vraiment de délire chez débouché
politique à déboucher institutionnels
est ce que ça veut dire que ce mouvement
qui co qui était un mouvement
extrêmement urbain un certain nombre de
villes de
france qui correspondait pas à beaucoup
de gens et ce qui a pas un décalage
entre sa dont on a beaucoup parlé et
puis la réalité du pays on va dire le
pays réel des petites villes des
campagnes de toutes ces choses là c'est
faux parce qu'il y avait plus de 100
endroits où venue de bois existe et les
militants du npa philippe poutou là où
il était présent ils ont participé
autant que faire se peut à côté
syndicalistes d'associatifs
effectivement y compris des gens qui
participent pas aux fondements de
l'opinion de gauche mais ce qui est
clair pour l'instant c'est que c'est là
que se retrouvent les facteurs de
renouveau et certainement pas dans la
réédition déchets mais c'est pour ça que
tant de gens ne savent pas trop ce
qu'ils vont aller jusqu'au bout du vote
que pour l'instant on donne dans les
sondages vous parlez de volatiles il y
une volatilité
elle est très près les sondages et son
appréhension parce que la pop les
propositions c'est une archi connu
effectivement que tu veuilles du bourg
est fait par la base pendant le sommet
mon avance sur ce qui s'est passé dans
la semaine encore et je me tourne vers
vous venez de latence écran soit fillon
doit faire avec cette enquête en cours
la nouveauté ça a été vendredi le
parquet décide de transmettre l'affairé
au juge aux juges oncle enquête qui se
poursuit ça veut dire qu'ils jugent
qu'il ya des éléments qui permettent de
continuer alors que vous aurez pu
décider d'arrêter
est-ce que rémy de l'at on peut faire on
sait que la présidentielle c'est une
course impitoyable
est-ce qu'on peut la faire avec un
boulet au pied pas bien sûr sur l'image
du bagnard à mettre sur le fed est
alourdi par quelque chose comme vous
comme vous j'ai entendu le déontologue
de l'assemblée nationale qui a dit très
clairement qu'ils avaient aucune
transgression par rapport au règlement
de l'assemblée nationale
j'ai entendu comme vous le parc national
financier qui n'avaient pas d'élément à
charge pour françois fillon
sinon je vous assure il leur est si tu
es devant une juridiction
aussitôt et aujourd'hui le fait de
renvoyer effectivement cette affaire
devant les juges répond à une
nouvelle disposition législative qui a
été votée il ya une dizaine de jours au
parlement et qui prévoit en effet de
pouvoir interrompre la prescription
donc ce qui est souhaitable dans cette
affaire mais plus largement à vider la
salle ça c'est des droits mais moi je
vous parle mais je vais vous dire je
suis même bien content que cette affaire
puisse être portée devant les juges et
qu'elles soient ainsi traités de façon
tout à fait normale par par la justice
avec tout le respect et toute la
confiance qu'on doit placer dans la
justice les français aujourd'hui je vais
vous dire
ils en ont assez et il dit ils disent
halte au sketch alto sketchs vous le
disiez vous même monsieur monsieur n'est
ni un instant je crois que trop c'est
trop et on voit bien que quand on veut
tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la rage
et bien aujourd'hui françois fillon
apparaît comme celui effectivement qui
est ensuite parti il y aurait pu y avoir
un abandon des poursuites rémi delattre
là vous nous dites que y'a rien dans le
dossier mais enfin il ya pour l'instant
sa chaîne sinon c'est mais sait s'il y
avait quelque chose et on aurait
évidemment françois fillon aurait été
cité devant une juridiction
il n'y a rien et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
y'a rien alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
des électeurs est-ce que vous avez assez
autant d'électeurs que vous pensiez en
avoir à cause de ça françois fillon il
est globalement à 20 pour global mans à
20% dans les sondages
on sait très bien que c'est beaucoup
plus faible que ce que votre parti
espérait à ce moment-là de la campagne
on est d'accord je vais on est encore 55
jours pour battre le terrain mais qu'est
ce que veulent les français aujourd'hui
ils se rendent comptent qu'aujourd'hui
françois hollande et toute l'équipe y
compris monsieur mac rhône il compris
monsieur maman ils ont mis le convoi de
la france dans le décor et aujourd'hui
comment au sort de tout ça c'est 9,7
pour cent de chômeurs c'est une saine
croissance à la traîne à la peine 1,1
pour cent quand la zone euro est 1,6
c'est une dette abyssale 31 mille euros
par part français + 92 milliards depuis
que françois hollande est arrivé c'est
ce bilan 2012 était pas si excellent que
ça mais attendez attendez on va en
parler du bilan précédent
mais c'est aussi un constat d'échec en
matière de sécurité en matière de
logement vous avez sans doute plus
le rapport oria il ya quelques jours de
la fondation de l'abbé pierre
et qui dit qu'il ya trente mille enfants
dans la rue en france 30 milles c'est
indigne
c'est indigne et 4 millions de français
qui sont mal logées voilà ce qui doit
nous prennent forme logicielle t as pas
avoir deux présidents face à vous sur
cet argumentaire émile delattre parce
que c'est pas évident vous n'avez pas
vraiment de cibles de cette campagne de
cible la cible c'est de rassurer les
français et de leur proposer un projet
françois fillon est celui qui a préparé
depuis très longtemps son projet il a
rencontré des gens quand je vois
emmanuel macron avec toute l'image qu'il
essaie de véhiculer qui est qui et où se
situaient les chansons qui constituent
l'essentiel de ce genre est distribuée
qui constitue l'essentiel de sa
dynamique aujourd'hui je ne regarderais
toutes les contradictions et bas
chercher dans le programme de fillon n'y
a aucune contradiction ont rebondi de
contrebande est sûre avant 10h00 puis on
va essayer une demi-heure êtes pois
jérôme m vous aussi vous vous en prenez
un bilan du quinquennat ou pas c c'est
ça votre cible ou votre cible vous ces
deux
dame née l'idée de l'intérêt général et
de sortir des de ce qui se faisait avant
ce qui est beaucoup plus facile d'une
certaine manière d'ailleurs nous nous ce
qu'on pense et d'ailleurs la démarche
que nous avons c'est que finalement pour
pour mener une politique en france le
président sortant françois hollande n'a
pas pu mener sa politique parce qu'il
n'avait pas la mort et la majorité qui
l'a élu n'a pas amené n'étaient pas
d'accord sur cette politique et c'est
tout le problème des primaires que l'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est à dire que se
rassembler alors qu'on n'est pas
d'accord que ce soit à droite ou que ce
soit à gauche fait qu'après on n'est pas
dans la capacité de gouverner la
différence c'est que notre mouvement à
nous aujourd'hui il est clair on peut
nous dire qu'on n'a pas de programme
notre programme
il existe on voit plaisanté le plan de
transformation aux français cette
semaine nous l'avons construit avec plus
de soixante mille français
nous avons fait plus de 60 réunions des
dans le département de la côte d'or en
trois mois pour retravailler sur
l'éducation sur la santé sur la sécurité
ces propositions elles sont remontées
elles enrichissent le programmes des
manuels dacron il déclina certains de
propositions depuis le meeting des
portes de versailles on était plus de
15000 à nevers à à lyon a limogé hier
dans l'oeuvre dans la haute vienne
donc ce projet vous pouvez dire qu'on en
a pas le nôtre il est clair il est
précis et il ne change pas celui de
françois fillon aujourd'hui on ne
connaît pas il ya trois mois il annoncé
un pro il annoncé un programme sur
lequel il a été élu à la primaire et je
vois que sur un certain nombre de
mesures sur la santé sont en train de
changer
kay et demain et demain qui est souvent
évoqué deux mois va pas changer quel
sera quel sera son projet qu'elle sera
projet de françois fillon demain quand
il sera et c'est quand il sera élu
je ne sais pas donc la clarté elle n'est
pas chez vous la clarté les chez nous et
c'est une partie qui rassemble c'est une
carte et qui a été construite par par
les citoyens vous parliez tout à l'heure
de nuit debout qui était un autre
mouvement citoyen avec lequel on n'est
pas d'accord
mais notre mouvement apprend sa génèse
dans justement cette réflexion
collective cette intelligence collective
cette intelligence citoyenne quel
mouvement marché c'est le fondement
notre nouveau
bollinger mais fondamentalement il ya
deux choses à cette affaire-là
on a à peu près les mêmes politiques non
pas sous le quinquennat mais sur les dix
années qui sont suivies que ce sommet
c'est sarkozy hollande est
malheureusement parce que ce que voter
hollande au deuxième tour des
présidentielles et à 5 ans espérait bien
et rittal changement est à noter que
plus déçu avec des conséquences que ça
sur l'application dans la vie politique
des citoyennes et citoyens
mais le deuxième élément de cette
affaire là aussi c'est que ce qu'on voit
venir
on nous dit le convoi france moi je veux
bien qu'on voit france des formules mais
qu'est ce que propose le suppliant sur
ce convoi qui est déjà dans la triste
état y propose de torpille a déjà un
wagon celui de la santé on a vu son
programme torpiller un autre wagon celui
des services publics
il faut supprimer des fonctionnaires en
pagaille et cetera et là dessus il ya
une large unanimité c'est toute la
classe
mais oui c'est la croatie faire trouver
des boucs émissaires et régler les
problèmes
le problème de fond est ce là est la
véritable cause de la désaffection
c'est justement qu'on a toujours d une
caste comme audi en espagne de
politiciens professionnels liés aux
milieux d'affaires qui est lié à la
finance qui est qu'ils travaillent avec
et qui c'est qu'a cette politique est
les citoyens et citoyennes à rejeter et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut des
professionnaliser la politique arrêtée
les mandats cumulés arrêté lé mandat à
vie que les citoyens actifs puissent à
tour de rôle
effectivement participé à la vie
l'adolescence est facilitée y compris la
participation des citoyens et citoyennes
c'est pas du tout ce que font les
professionnels
j'allais dire il n'y a pas de carrière
politique ça devrait pas exister je veux
dire alors là je découvre ça je savais
pas que françois hollande ait pas de
majorité en 2012
la maison il a eu un groupe socialiste
avec les verts s'étaient certes une
alliance un peu saugrenue aux gens
combien d comme lys qui ont été fidèles
dès le départ mais il a tellement déçu
qu'à la fin effectivement il est utilisé
en cavale nationale avait bien vu qu'ils
avaient cas sur son oeuvre ses
contradictions
l'indicé vers le haut sur les fausses a
dit emmanuel macron sur les
contradictions des manuels me convient
dit sur mon projet est tout à fait clair
mais sur les 35 heures au mois de
novembre
emmanuel macron dit aux 35 heures c'est
pas assez quand on est jeune on peut
travailler plus en décembre un mois plus
tard il dit on garde les 35 heures sur
l'indemnisation du chômage
libérés les sources indemnisation du
chômage
monsieur macron dit en janvier 2016 il
faut explorer de nouvelles règles
d'indemnisation on pourra pas continuer
comme ça et en octobre 2016 il est
opposé à toute transformation toute
modification toute l'agressivité
disons que ce serait la plus injuste
mesure issue à telenet sur le chemin sur
le diesel le maquereau et les échecs je
verrai chez chômage il faut pas faire la
guerre au diesel et maintenant il dit il
faut faire rentrer au regel aller
jusqu'à la suspension assurance
assurance chômage universel c'est une
véritable révolution que nous proposons
à ce sujet nous proposons que chacun et
chacune puisse avoir un droit au chômage
a droit assorti à des devoirs
un droit qui sera proposé aux
commerçants aux artisans aux
agriculteurs aux indépendants
c'est-à-dire que nous souhaitons sortir
cette assiette logique assurantielle du
chômage est passé à un droit au chômage
pour tout le monde qui sera financé par
la solidarité nationale parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'assurance chômage ne
correspond plus au monde dans lequel
nous vivons est ce que ce que le
mouvement en marche montre c'est que
nous aujourd'hui nous avons des valeurs
ces valeurs sont celles de la france la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité
on veut libérer on veut protéger et on
veut aussi adapter ces valeurs-là au
monde dans lequel on vit
on est confiant dans la capacité de
notre pays à sa à s'adapter et à réussir
dans ce nouveau monde
on veut un monde une france de
conquérant une france telle que tels que
la france des lumières a toujours été et
c'était une france à la pointe une
france qui fait confiance à ses acteurs
à ses citoyens
on a cette capacité là et j'ai nous
sommes nombreux à le croire et nous
sommes nombreux à le penser et nous
sommes nombreux à vous
agir ensemble n'est plus de 200 milles
et 8,5 mais je vais tout seul pour vous
il ya un point qu'on avait prévu de
parler et c'est aussi pour ça que vous
êtes avec nous ils volent un gc de
l'adif la réforme des signatures pour
les les candidatures on sait que votre
candidat philippe poutou ces insurgés
cette semaine alors c'est un point de
détail à un report de deux jours
l'ouverture de la période c'est un peu
administratif mais de façon plus large
il semblerait que cette réforme des
signatures et elle a un lien avec ce
dont on parle aujourd'hui parce que ça
peut modifier le paysage de la
présidentielle du nombre de candidats
que cette réforme est l'aboutissement
fait que des candidats habituels comme
les candidats de l'extrême gauche et du
mal à voir leur signature
est ce que c'est vrai ils vont manger et
de votre point de vue qu'est ce que ça
signifie
c'est évidemment vrai parce que on a une
difficulté et pas seulement si les
poteaux
je pense que toute candidature plus
diverses d'ailleurs tu m'aimes feu mais
phénomène est la conséquence pratique
c'est que tous ces séries de partie du
spectre du débat politique n'est pas
représenté dans le débat que ce soit
d'ailleurs valable pour les élections
présidentielles les barrages du même
type existent sur d'autres scrutins
et dans ces conditions là une bonne
partie des citoyens des citoyens sont
laissés sur la touche
c'est effectivement tout à fait
contraire à tout principe démocratique
mais le deuxième élément de la faire
aussi c'est que ça ne permet pas
d'avancer sur les débats de fond puisque
ce sont des machines électorales
traditionnelle qui monopolisent les
éléments de pouvoir y compris en termes
d'argent tant nos moyens si de suite que
les unes les autres d'ailleurs on peut
s'appeler en marche et se pétant de
nouveau et avoir tout heureux des moyens
tout à fait significatif que les petites
formations n'ont pas de ce côté là tout
le monde n'est quand même pas dans le
même cas de figure
mais les citoyens oui bien sûr mais y
compris tu te sauver la ferme et enfin
goûter bon vous êtes quand même le
représentant d'un candidat qui sort de
la banque qu'ils cornell qui en est le
fait le féal total plus de 6 tonnes ne
soyons pas naïfs à personne ici n'a
doute cette question là alors que sa
trompe un certain temps à ces zones de
citoyen à citoyen c'est une chose la
réalité c est ce que les difficultés
qu'a philippe poutou pour avoir sa
signature ça dit quelque chose aussi sur
par exemple le fait que l'extrême gauche
qui a eu une audience assez forte aux
élections présidentielles on se souvient
de de volume cumulé 10 % des voix en
2002 au premier tour aujourd'hui ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que ces idées un
prix - un prix non plus parce que les
mères y donner leur signature parce que
ça correspondait à quelque chose dans la
société aussi s'il est donc plus est-ce
que c'est lié à ça aussi il est de ne
plus parce que d'une certaine manière
les maires sont généralement pour la
plupart de ceux qu'on a constaté des
personnes qui prennent sur leur temps en
plus de leur travail professionnel pour
gérer les affaires des citoyens
l'immense majorité des mères ce sont des
travailleurs aussi et cela en ont un peu
las de la situation qui est faite aux
élus en termes de statut des énigmes à
spa des ventes de signature à quelques
ados et pour faire légalement mais ce
qui est font surtout par rapport à nous
et par rapport aux forces qui cherchent
à changer un peu la société sur le fond
c'est ya un doute et ce doute qui se
traduit sur le doute cette institution
les gens préfèrent s'abstenir pour ça
que ça ne changera pas il vaut mieux
peut-être quand même que revoir
complètement le fonctionnement
démocratique que laisser le terrain à
des situations où donald trump gagne
pour des politiques qui pensons-nous
catastrophique ses émules ville verse
aux pays bas madame le pen en france et
ainsi de suite
de ce point de vue là à force de jouer
les barrages pour la vie démocratique au
fini par faire fabriquer des forces qui
l'a détruiront s'il arrivait au pouvoir
pour la première fois de la cinquième
république
cinq candidats plus de 10 % dans les
sondages jamais arrivé on est dans une
configuration nouvelle
avec aussi un scandale un ticket
d'accession deuxième tour qui se situera
aux alentours de 20% ça ressemble un peu
à 2002 c'est quoi la sensation que vous
avez vous de cette campagne en ce moment
il n'y a jamais eu autant clairement
d'affaires judiciaires qui concernaient
des candidats c'est un drôle de moment
démocratique
je crois que le monge bougent le monde
bouge par de rossi faisait mois la
société aujourd'hui elles expriment des
attentes de façon un peu différente de
ce qu'on a pu connaître dans le passé et
c'est vrai que cette élection elle est
d'ailleurs les médias et les instituts
de sondages l'ont montré toute la
difficulté qu'ils avaient à bien
appréhender effectivement ces scrutins
on a vu pour les primaires en
particulier autant à droite qu'à gauche
et on sent bien aujourd'hui qu'il ya des
choses qui bougent parce que là les
campagnes se font plus de façon
traditionnelle comme avant on n'est plus
maintenant appliqué dans les réseaux
sociaux et et on voit bien que les
choses les choses bougent pour autant je
crois que à 60 jours à peu près de
l'élection présidentielle on a encore
deux mois il peut se passer beaucoup de
choses et en particulier regardez la
dynamique qui est cédée les dernières
élections les tendances sont peu dans la
dans la primaire personne ne le donnent
gagnant
nous nous sentions des choses et on
ressent aujourd'hui des choses sur le
terrain
on a passé une période difficile j'en
conviens bien mais aujourd'hui on est en
train de regagner de retravailler sur le
fond justement et toute la crédibilité
du candidat fillon est en train
d'émerger et vous savez c'est une
élection n'est jamais gagnée d'avancé et
je suis à cet égard très prudent mais on
a des forces militantes dynamique qui
s'engagent et et au sang on sent que les
choses reprennent et reprennent en
faveur de l'émission est quasi terminée
juste un petit mois j'ai re même là
dessus sur les sondages qui vous ont
placé très haut finalement un moment
donné est-ce que vous l'attendiez est ce
que c'est un service que ça vous a rendu
on est sur un mouvement de fond emmanuel
macron à créer son mouvement le 6 avril
dernier
très vite il a pris dans la société
civile
on a vu cette cette aspiration des
français pour ce mouvement et pour les
propositions que connaissent de rasseoir
avec la volatilité annoncé de
l'électorat s'est fait peur ça non parce
que vous êtes le parti dans mon conseil
que les électeurs sont le moins su pour
lequel ils sont moins sûrs de voter mais
nous si quelques mots politique le plus
jeune et le plus récent de ce pays nous
avons même pas dix mois est néanmoins
nous rassemblons énormément de français
donc forcément il y aura une volatilité
mais si je peux juste aller à jean marie
g cette année voilà merci à tous les
trois d'eads venus débattre sur ce
plateau on rappelle qu'on va continuer
les présidentielles sur france 3 tous
les dimanches et puis qu'on attendait
une candidate du front national qui
n'est pas venu à la demande de sa
présidente de groupe au conseil régional
sophie montel
restez avec nous c'est jean christophe
cambadélis qui sera l'invité de francis
letellier dans la partie nationale de
dimanche en politique
bon dimanche au revoir et merci
[Musique]